[Musique]
en mettant les pieds à raleigh le
constat s'impose immédiatement
la ville à l'effet d'un aimant
nous
avec ses universités ces deux
laboratoires et ses entreprises
technologiques la caroline du nord
attire bien des américains ici 44 % des
résidents sont nés à l'extérieur de
l'etat sera aux crédits et sa famille
ont choisi il y à 80 s'expatrier dans la
région de raleigh pour cette
new-yorkaise c'était un changement de
décor majeur un poids financier de plus
en plus difficile à porter
quand son mari a reçu une offre d'emploi
en caroline du nord la décision a été
simple à prendre a même créé un blog
pour documenter son expérience et
éclairé d'autres new york est tenté de
déménager parce que n'est pas seul à
migrer vers le sud
car oui la banlieue où elle est établie
porte même le surnom de containment
eurockéennes qu'ils zone de confinement
pour aix new yorkais
[Musique]
rihanna plus de gens de partout du pays
dans notre région présente chaque jour
en moyenne
on a quarante deux personnes qui
viennent de quelque part pour
s'installer comme ses collègues l'agent
immobilier kodjo koussou et témoin
privilégié de la croissance de cette
région où les nouveaux développements
pousse très rapidement parmi ses clients
des jeunes professionnels évidemment
mais aussi beaucoup de retraités
le coût de vie parce que le jeu prend sa
retraite et qu'il a menacé un budget
limité
il verrait ses quelque part où le coût
de vie ne va pas dépasser en face on
revenait manche et c'est une fois à la
retraite que joël oman s'est installé
près de raleigh de son new york natal il
ne regrette rien même ici il peut
trouver des souvenirs de son ancien chai
nuit
quand il est arrivé zhao avait des
appréhensions
des gens lent avec un accent ses prix
jugé à propos du sud se sont vite
effacés
au delà leur nourriture les expatriés
new yorkais emmène avec lui une partie
de leur culture
la caroline du nord n'est pas le seul
endroit attrayant pour ces américains
qui veulent déménager là georges et la
floride l'arizona le texas
plusieurs états du sud et de l'ouest ont
connu d'importants gains migratoires ces
dernières années des changements
démographiques qui ont des impacts
politiques qui peut comme une preuve
pour cette experte c'est l'un des
facteurs qui fait en sorte que certains
états rouge change tranquillement de
couleurs
[Musique]
en 2016 dans notre show pas remporté la
caroline du nord avec une marge de peu
moins de quatre points de pourcentage
dans cet état du sud ou tiers de la
population vit dans des zones rurales
le président a toujours de bons appuis
mais la partie n'est pas gagnée
la militante and bones républicaine
convaincue reconnaît que les changements
démographiques représente un défi pour
son parti originaire de la caroline du
nord elle lance un message aux électeurs
démocrates qui ont adopté son état huit
ans après son arrivée à kerry l'ex new
yorkaise sara o'grady ne changerait pour
rien au monde son mode de vie
quant à la politique c'était les crises
libéral voit même des avantages à vivre
dans un état plus républicain l'état en
pleine transformation qui pourrait être
déterminant dans le résultat de
l'élection
[Musique]